this is the bismillah alhamdulillah
welcome to the Deen show I'm Eddie your
host we have an exciting show for you
today
911 let me tell my Floyd money
Mayweather into my 50 Cent's and Hearn
in our special guests here on the D show
so much to talk to you about don't go
nowhere for this exciting episode of the
D show we'll be right back
back on the DS show welcome welcome
como estas amigos yeah hamdullah peace
be with you assalamualaikum
waalaikumsalam a little bit of Spanish
Arabic English absolutely
bilingual I'm how are you doing Hernan
yes open the show and I'm talking about
Hernan I'm talking about 9/11 we're
talking about Floyd Mayweather in the
mix undefeated boxing champ 50 Cent's
how do you fit in with 50 Cent's and and
employed money Mayweather and this is an
exciting show but before we give the
audience the bigger picture we're gonna
have you introduce yourself Hernan
jiu-jitsu superstar we got boxing Jitsu
people things like what are you going to
be fighting challenging Floyd Mayweather
maybe one day for fun hamdullah my name
is Hernan voila Lupe is pronounced Aaron
an in Spanish Oh habla espanol I will
explain you know poquito oh yeah my my
parents they they traveled over here
from Ecuador in the late 70s hum do the
searching that better life they left you
know their futures their careers behind
in in search to provide for myself and
for my brothers something better
alhamdulillah yeah so tell us now you
you have a very exciting story on 9/11
which we know that this was a sad event
only an idiot will be sitting there
celebrating that women died children
died you know a whites died blacks died
non Muslims died Muslims died so we know
that Islam has nothing to do with this
right so we're not revisiting this we
know that Islam and Islamic scholars
have condemned this but you now and just
one more thing to know I mean FBI
statistics you know because many people
Islamophobes and people who are trying
to make Islam out like the boogeyman
just look at the facts
you know it's Lamas on the look was
showing a chart right now to show an
Islam even though that anyone who's
doing terrorist asks has nothing to do
they're doing it according to their own
desires and whims but look at Islam is
at the lower
totem pole according to FBI statistics
look at these charts so we're not going
to go in that's not the topic other
people can look at the other topics that
we've covered condemning this but now
you accepted Islam that's submission to
the one who created you the one got on
9/11 correct okay so before we get into
50 cents money Mayweather and all this
and how disconnect your jujitsu your
also jiu-jitsu player you Brazilian
Jujitsu talk to us what happened why did
this happen well my parents when they
came over here they they wanted that
better lifestyle for us and one of the
ways that they felt would be a a
catalyst to having a good lifestyle is
to enroll us in a Catholic school so
from first grade all the way to eighth
grade I was in Catholic school and
during that time we learned about the
Bible catechism took all my sacraments
and and also I was an altar boy during
that during that time from fourth grade
to eighth grade and I was in the church
I was I was learning I was studying I
was assisting and you're behind the
scenes seeing pretty much everything for
the for a long time it was just
following what what was instructed but
it came to a point where everybody youth
comes in into their lives and started
asking themselves what's their purpose
in life what is my goal what am i doing
and then and at the same time because I
was in a religious environment I started
asking religious questions I started
asking about the the Trinity and the
concept of God and Catholicism in its
theology and its practices and certain
things never lined up my heart never
really accepted these things even though
I followed it for so long but it came to
a point where I started asking these
questions and it just it didn't click
like one plus one plus one is still one
and I was always into math and it
doesn't make sense
I'm what the Holy Ghost God like this is
God and my father to God right
but not three gods one guy doesn't make
sense it didn't make sense and you're
taught and you're taught in math that
one plus one plus one is three
but then in theology you're taught that
3 is 1 or 1 is 3 and it's just it just
didn't make sense and on top of the fact
that there were certain things that that
you saw that you just didn't feel that
were right and one of the big one of the
things was the the amount of wealth that
was collected the amount of gold that
was stored and then you'd go outside and
you see many people living in poverty
and it just it's just something inside
of me never really felt that this was
the correct way so I started a journey
of searching the truth I had friends
that were different denominations of
Christianity I started asking them
questions about their faiths I read
about Judaism Hinduism I was into
kung-fu when I was a kid so I started
learning I started you get a black bone
come true
I studied for 10 years 10 years but I
never really in in kung-fu there is a
black belt but they go more go by like
stashes rather than colours he's like
Shifu right Sifu so I I studied it and I
competed against the black belt level
but it was so it was such a challenge
that I stayed writing them cut in the
middle but um but yes why because I was
into that type of culture I'd also
looked into the Chinese religion and but
nothing ever clicked nothing ever really
stood out and said you know what this is
what I want to choose and and it didn't
happen
until I actually got to college and
actually before that I remember when I
was about 16 about 17 or 18 years old I
made oh I made I made supplication to to
God to guide me because I felt lost I
mean now when you say God were you
talking about what many Christians
believe Holy Ghost God Jesus God who
which God are you talking about Allah
the the only one the one true God you
never said a law at that time no I did
what no no you would define for people
who've never heard this term who are you
praying to the creator of the heavens
and the earth the one who we all seek
from the one who doesn't
need anything or anyone he's the
provider the the the protector the
Creator the one who doesn't have any
children or doesn't or wasn't born would
it be safe to say where this was because
Christians considered like the father
the ultimate yes okay the supreme the
Supreme Being
so you're praying to the Supreme Being
the created not not to create it not not
Jesus where I'm the Holy Spirit that I
was I had a about all the saints that
come into the mix and Catholicism what
about say I michaeljudy this Saint
that's saying were you pranked or any of
them
no absolutely not I mean for me at that
age I already understood that these
people there were just people like us
and the only reason that they were
raised to that status wasn't because
people raised them to that status God
didn't give them that status per se so
for me I was going straight to the
source so now you pray to the Creator
because you want to know your purpose in
life exactly so I found myself one night
crying just waterfalls of tears and
asking God to guide me asking Allah to
guide me and give me the truth to show
me what the truth is and really I
thought the truth was gonna come the
next day I mean it was such a sincere
sincere supplication that I I really
believed that the truth was gonna be
just fall into my lap the next day but
didn't happen that way
so I continued my life and because I was
so caught up in in the mix of the youth
doing things that you do partying and
going out and other vices that you know
we don't want to mention but you kind of
get the idea you you sort of kind of got
deviated from you know from those from
believing or or you just kind of started
in you know delving into things that are
not permissible or so now you're now
you're away from so you went from being
into religious religious to now it not
making sense not me being able to
comprehend certain things how about
asking questions to the higher-ups I
mean they stopped after a while because
the only response to that that they came
down to was son you just have to believe
and I used to ask myself how can I
believe in something that I don't
understand how how is it that God has
made this religion the religion for all
of mankind yet there are so many
ambiguities so many holes that we just
can't comprehend so I just got
disenchanted and just stepped away and I
ended up saying I never disbelieved that
there was God I always believed that God
existed or the Supreme Being existed and
you would say I kind of fell into being
agnostic you would say so you believe in
God but not necessarily specific faith
you're not following a specific way and
that was like that for a long time you
know through high school even my earlier
zuv college and then when I got to
college I finally met a gentleman who
was Muslim he was another student with
with me and we got together through
through other means not necessarily
religious means and we started hanging
out playing basketball we would get
together in the dorm rooms to hang out
and we started talking about different
topics government religion sports
current events and all these boxing
boxing music Marcia martial art he was
big into martial arts he was big in a
martial art now did you get from going
to religious to going towards the 50
cent lifestyle by you know the celebrity
lifestyle that's where we're going to
kind of lead into also with that Floyd
money Mayweather and $0.50 where you
either like menudo yeah Ricky Martin and
her young okay so those are the people
now did you at one point your license to
be on stage like that I want to be you
know a star yeah I mean everybody
everybody I mean for the most part kids
youth that are there in college there
they're there to make money I mean
they're there to you know to get the
education but the goal is to become
successful so status and monies are
never late let's hold it right there
we're going to take a break we got so
much more to talk about and I'm not
gonna let you down we mention at the
beginning all these big names 50-cent
Floyd money Mayweather Hernan boxing
jiu-jitsu put them up against each other
so much more don't go anywhere
when outside everything looks good you
see the hundred thousand dollar cars you
see a lot of diamonds you see a lot of
females and they think that this is you
know this is a life this is this is like
no paradise right here our job to go
into someone's heart to change the
heartbeat your job is to topi what the
truth is and then the alley over there
while we're sitting here while I'm
sitting here constantly paying for the
disease the cure was free
I am Not Afraid
back here with Hernan and we have a very
exciting show for you 911 we mentioned
911 that you accepted the purpose of
life on 9/11 the purpose of life that
the creator sent down not man-made the
man-made way of life it wasn't making
sense and no man-made way of life at you
try to fit it on the whole globe of
humanity it's not going to make sense
from the crater it's got to make sense
one plus one is two one is one is not
the three and all this other
mathematical gymnastics that don't make
sense
so now you're in college right and now
that's like for some people this party
City I mean for me was primetime because
this was the first time I was actually
actually out of my heart I'm yeah I was
actually out of my house my family again
do you know they were very protective of
us so this was the first time I was
living on my own oh boy that's a big you
know and and I really pretty much came
out of my shell during that time because
now supervision at home people parent
you kind of a little shy to do certain
think all right but now you're outside
of the house right okay so you kind of
got into the I got into the mix you know
meeting a lot of people socializing
attending parties I joined the Latino
fraternity that was very social oh boy
now you're in a fraternity yeah okay and
this is all about parties and they might
do some good things but at the end of
the day it's like do some good things so
we can party harder I mean that was for
some people was like yeah and so so I
was I was into this stuff and at the
same time I still was in that search and
I met my friend he he he introduced me
to Islam during these little these small
little gatherings and he would talk
about it and he would talk about all
these topics politics government's
current events sports and all that stuff
from an Islamic angle so there's the
first time I heard the word Allah the
the word Muhammad you know these the
name Muhammad Islam and this was brand
new to me I didn't I never heard this
before
and and it's funny because when I think
about it Allah or God he in my in my
life I was introduced to all these
religions and I thought I knew it all
but I never learned about his lemon so
this specific point and my heart was
drawn to it because it made sense
to me when I asked and I started asking
him the questions I would ask the
priests so when I asked him okay what do
you believe how do you how do you define
the Trinity what who is God who is Jesus
he would tell me from the Islamic point
of view and it entered my heart and it
filled my heart with happiness it was
for the first time there was that click
that I was looking for one is one no
complications
Jesus was a messenger and a prophet he
was just a man who was sent with a
message there they were to deliver
mankind with glad tidings of worshipping
Allah alone and entering paradise that
makes sense who's Mary Mary is the
mother of Jesus not the mother of God
because then there's a circle that you
just can't understand because if she's
the mother of garden the mother of Jesus
then how is it that God gave her life
but she gave me life to God and it's
just too confusing but when she when he
explained that Mary was just a woman a
righteous pious woman who gave birth to
Jesus the messenger it made sense all
the questions were loose if the answers
were lucid and clear clear no ambiguity
oh and the purpose of life was it
answered now yes and the satisfaction of
your soul yes and when I asked him what
is what is our purpose in this life he
would ask what mahalik to gina well insa
illa li
abuddin that we're not here that God
didn't create Allah didn't create any
the man and the and the jinn kind except
to worship Him and that made sense and
when he said everything is worship you
come into school as worship you you
waking up in the morning is worship you
eating is what everything and I was like
that makes sense as long as your God
conscious you're doing it with the right
intentions to please God to serve God
that's an act of worship and one of my
biggest things growing up was like why
do I have to pray in the church for God
to answer my prayers what if he knows
everything and sees everything why can't
I pray at home and the privacy of my own
home and that was one of the biggest
challenges for me growing up and when he
told me your relationship is with God
alone there's no intermediary you're not
praying to Jesus you're not praying the
Saints you're praying wherever you want
except certain areas of course but
wherever you want but directly to God
and for me that was that's what I was
looking no secretary in the middle no
sir just direct dial up
you talked about procrastination you
figured out within your very self your
innate nature was like pulling you is
drawing you to while the other belief it
was just something that just didn't make
sense and your insides it didn't connect
with your insides are connecting with
this absolutely but now you talk to me
before a little bit I heard that you
were procrastinating a lot right now
9/11 comes in a mix tell us about this
so like I mentioned you're caught up in
in this lifestyle you know the Floyd
money Mayweather lifestyle descent
lifestyle
menudo lifestyle you know maybe not to
that extreme but definitely you wanted
to be successful you know I wanted a BMW
I'm one of my own house I want I want
this and these things are good in the
sense but you know you're this is this
is what most guys at college that's what
they want become presidents of company
CEOs and stuff and and that's my
direction as well you know I wanted to
be a successful engineer but I didn't I
went out when I was learning about Islam
my heart accepted it completely I said I
told myself this is the religion that
I'm gonna be this is the really in there
that I want to be part of but right now
I'm having too much fun this is the
first time out of my house I'm meeting
all these people I'm having I'm going to
all these parties socializing and and I
just don't want to let this go yet so I
told myself I'm gonna wait until I get
older to accept Islam once you know
you're serious and you're more
established and stuff procrastination
right I procrastinate one of the devil's
biggest tricks all right you got time
right exactly and then and then what one
day happened September 11th came up to
this point I accepted a slim in my heart
but in action I said you know what I
gotta wait because I'm just I'm enjoying
my life right now I ended up going into
class in the morning and the university
that I attended Stevens Tech is actually
it's in Hoboken New Jersey
so Hoboken is actually on the bank of
the Hudson River so they say faces
Manhattan lower Manhattan it's directly
across the river so I went to I went to
class I came back to class and my friend
gave me a call on the phone so I
answered the call and she said that the
buildings are on fire I mean the Twin
Towers were on fire and I was like
that's impossible
I just saw them coming back from class
and they were fine
she said no turn it on turn it on and
check it out so I turned on the news and
lo and behold they were on fire and I
started freaked out I mean what's going
on you know
this mean this is a monument that it's a
historic monument be like you know
you're really in awe I ran up to my
friend and my friend's room the one who
was giving me down with Muslim brother
was getting me down and we both ran
outside to see what was going on and it
was chaotic I mean the the school was
full of students scared worried
concerned and by this time everybody
knew there was two planes that hit I
mean people saw it and there was reports
already that a plane struck the the the
towers and we were all in shock and
actually at that point I was really
really freaked out because the school
were where I went also has a huge Tower
as well so I kept on thinking what about
it for another plane hits here and
something happens to us and we're right
here and during that whole time where
I'm concerned and it wasn't until the
building's actually collapsed you know
after a couple hours the building's
actually collapsed that reality hit the
reality hit me and I thought to myself
at that time all these people they woke
up in the morning thinking that was
gonna be another normal day thinking
that they would have another tomorrow
they were gonna wake up have breakfast
have lunch have dinner hang out with
their friends family members play sports
whatever they did during the day they
thought they were going to do but a lot
had a different plan for them Allah
decreed that this was their final day
and for me visual or seeing that from
across the river and also knowing that
Islam is the truth that there's a reward
for those people who believe in Allah
and worship Him alone paradise and
there's also a destination for those who
disobey who want to follow their desires
who want to disobey Allah there is a
specific place for them as well knowing
this and knowing at that same time that
I was being arrogant procrastinating and
putting it off
being a servants of Allah obeying him
alone worshiping him alone because I
wanted to have fun
it scared me and realizing that what
about tomorrow
I don't live what about if tomorrow I
don't have an opportunity to become
Muslim what about when I when I'm 80 it
did never comes for me it was it was a
real shock I used to I remember even
what looking at my watch and just seeing
that the the seconds pass by and
worrying what's gonna happen next
at that moment my friend he taps me on
my shoulder and the same friend he
tapped me showing he says look this is
too much for me I need to go to back to
my room I want to go pray and without
any hesitation without even thinking
well you know what if I go with him and
I've you know and I follow him and pray
with him that I might not you know it's
gonna be a life change and then all the
parties and all that stuff is gonna be
gone I didn't even think about that at
that point I all I thought about was I
need to do the right thing I went back
with him to his room he showed me how to
make ablution wudu he taught me how to
say Shahada the declaration of faith and
I prayed with him for the first time and
from that point on I became Muslim and
so from that point on you submitted to
the will of God that's what a Muslim is
one who submits themselves not to a man
a monkey a woman to Jesus a messenger to
Muhammad but you submit to the one who
created all of them yes yeah you did
that I did that at that point and humbly
that was the the best decision that I
ever made I mean every and you know all
the all the the thoughts that I needed
to wait in order to and let me just
enjoy my life it wasn't the case once I
accepted its then I was completely happy
there was ways for us to have fun as
Muslims healthy fun and on top of that
my relationship with my parents got
better with my brother got better I felt
that I knew what my I had a direction
and purpose now I had the the roadmap on
how to lead my life all the things that
the vices that were really hurting me
you know they were finally washed away
and I had a clear path and it was the
best thing from Dilla that I that I did
for myself you know the tranquility and
peace sent to your heart lutely
absolutely you had purpose now you had a
plan absolutely God's plan not your
desire is dictating your way right was
clear it was clear happiness happiness
complete happiness something that money
can't buy money can't buy that yeah
we're gonna take a break and we'll
continue on and now for all the fans who
are tuning in just to hear what we have
to say about the undefeated heavyweight
no was he a junior heavyweight or what
is it he's likely and like light
heavyweight champion sorry we're saying
that wrong and 50 cent that one of the
most popular rap artists out in the
world we're going to be bringing this
into the mix when we come back so don't
go anywhere
an exciting show with Hernan here on the
Dean show we'll be right back say to me
why have you become a 'muslim know I
give a very frivolous on so I say I want
to be on the side of the Angels [ __ ] is
the guy she's the number one rap artists
in the world he's sold over 60 million
records worldwide Emilien Steve Miller
he was a young guy where basically
everything that somebody you would think
that life is all about he had everything
you can imagine
I am not afraid to stand alone I am Not
Afraid
back here on the Dean show with Hernan
accepted aslam submission to the will of
the one God the way of life of all the
messengers Jesus was a Muslim he
submitted to God Moses Abraham and last
the final mention of Prophet Muhammad
who is till the end of time a messenger
just like all of them will call people
to submit to the Creator don't submit to
the creation do good deeds obey God you
get to paradise disobey God follow your
desires consequences Hellfire and we
care that's what we're sharing so now
your story inshallah God willing can
affect so many people's lives you are
procrastinating like many people they
tune in and they say man that makes
sense
only worship the one who created
creation don't worship the creatures of
God worship the Creator alone don't set
up a partner with God as soon as you put
divinity - Holy Ghost - a saint you've
cancelled out pure monotheism and this
is what it's about pure monotheism so
Floyd money Mayweather now he's involved
at a higher level into the sport game
and his sidekick his best friend who we
want to invite to the purpose of life
you know the purpose of life now and
you're happy something that money cannot
buy you have and you know a little bit
about Floyd and all what do you know
about him
I remember watching him when I was
younger you know undefeated boxer
probably one of the most popular boxing
figures there is now so a real good
boxer undefeated right undefeated yeah
and and I've know have you noticed after
some of his bouts usually from the ones
that I've seen he thanks God but exactly
what is that power that allows you to
overcome those obstacles God what else
could I say God
he says you know I'd like to thank God
he doesn't throw Jesus in the mix almost
say I liked which that doesn't take I
mean Jesus was a mighty Messenger of God
nowhere did he ever call people to
worship Him never did he claimed he was
God but now a Floyd Mayweather he does
thank God at the end yeah so he there's
hope for everybody to change so anybody
who's admiring 50 cent and Floyd money
Mayweather if they continue to follow
them is that the right way or wrong way
swearing cursing partying did you know
all these other things that go against
what the crater wants us to do it's
definitely a highway it's not the right
way so tell us now you're involved in in
jujitsu yes okay did you have a box I
did I did you don't do some boxing
kickboxing yeah so now it's very
important now we as Muslims once who has
submitted to the rule of God we know the
purpose if you actually you don't care
you don't share so we as Muslim every
Muslims duty is to deliver the message
to share the purpose of life with the
world and what better person to share
with then some of these high up
celebrities that men if they come to the
realization that this is the truth
provide it provided that if I it
provides proof it provides evidence not
blind faith like you experienced many of
their followers
they'll also investigate and that's what
we want people to do to ask those tough
questions to their higher-ups to
investigate and they'll come to the same
realization if they're sincere that
Islam is from the crater it provides all
the proof of evidences that is is a true
so we know that the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him that he made a dua you
know this dua
when the person of that time Umar ibn
Khattab bloody alone he was like a
person of prestige
people admired him and tell us a bit
about this yeah I remember reading about
this um the Prophet peace be upon him he
actually made to offer to people in his
in his tribe the first one was armed are
even Hisham or Abuja had he's best known
in history and Alma been a hot tub and
he said o Allah strengthen Islam through
one other to through one of the two
because during that time these two
gentlemen were
were affluent they were they had you
know prestige in power and influence on
the people so the prophet peace be upon
him he made the odd that a lobby excuse
me at the Aslam be uplifted and
strengthened through one of these two
gentlemen and hamdullah it was Alma with
a hot tub that Allah guided and accepted
us them and we know that he was the
Prophet peace be upon him said if there
was any other prophet to be after me it
would've been shut up so you could see
the status that Islam become was raised
that just through this gentleman and it
reminds me and when we talk about these
celebrities or in discussions you know
these people have influence they people
follow them you know whether it be
Mayweather or 50 cent or or any other
individual in entertainment or sports
business they have followings people
flock to them millions of followers
millions maybe some people worship
that's like an actor what people worship
them some of them do they do because
they know everything about their lives
if they say turn left they'll turn left
where this the word that jump like this
don't jump like that they dictate they
dictate how society pretty much late
lives their life and especially the
youth and and it the hadith or the store
I reminds me of that because so imagine
if you make their offer these people or
invite them to Islam the the effect that
they can have on their immediate
following you know and and we've seen it
before we've seen it with other other
singers and rappers Muhammad Ali Cat
Stevens even like the current times and
look Napoleon and Luna and all these
people and I know you've had them on
your show so these people they have an
influence so you show that it's it would
be a great thing that you know this
person also comes into them and have
that impact upon it
and that's what we want to do right now
because now with all the money the
millions he gets paid like for Floyd
money Mayweather they call him used to
be pretty boy floyd and he pull out the
like the stack of hundreds mythic
counting millions in front of he's in
jail now and his money can't get him out
right now he's in jail for domestic
violence and usually when people are
closed behind four doors now they'll
reflect and think and his money can't
save them now he'll be
I think in in in in a few weeks and a
little bit over a month something like
that but he has now we have a way to get
a hold of him before people like man how
can we invite him but we're putting up
on a screen now his address so we're
asking people it's a call to action
send Floyd money Mayweather a letter on
why he should be a Muslim that family
and Allah will facilitate the way let's
plant the seed because if maybe I send a
letter you that's one out of how many
does he get but imagine if all the
thousands of Muslim millions of Muslims
now start writing him a letter one
letter and inviting him and giving him
the reasons why he should be a Muslim
maybe tomorrow when he reads it he might
accept and then all his followers all of
them start looking into it and maybe
they'll accept this way of life that's
from the crater Islam - or you know what
maybe in 20 years hey those those
letters that he got all the thousands
you know
impact they can have an impact on him
and then he's going to share with the
sidekick 50 cents maybe it's 50 cents
drop in it and it's true everything
they've done in the past okay let's say
they turned to Islam they turned to the
Creator all of them sins are forgiven if
they turn to God Almighty sincerely all
of the evil that they might have done
slate is clean the slate is clean that's
amazing right so any closing comments
and suggestions now you also have some
some books your website now you've doing
some great you're actively involved in
the Dawa so so tell us where people get
ahold of you we are when I became you
know after I became Muslim you know and
being involved in the Latino community
there's not that many resources for
spanish-speaking Muslims and even
non-muslims so we took the initiative to
translate a lot of articles into Spanish
that people can benefit from and one of
the and the sister company or sister
project is actually making books for
spanish-speaking children so we notice
there's a lot of Latinos just like
myself are having children hamdullah
becoming Muslim they're Muslim from
birth there are no resources for them to
learn so we've actually made books my
wife is she's the main director on this
project she actually writes and
publishes her own books what's the
website that people can get to set the
table most Islam
Nino's so people can get these books
here
say it again habla moses lam Nino's so
we have about five books that we publish
today that they can come as coloring
books you know great printing and grow
bright that they can benefit and she'll
and it to use them you know a number of
Islamic values like how to go to Juma
and the importance of the veil and how
to you know how to prepare for Ramadan
yeah stuff like that
tell us now we're out of time we got
like 30 seconds now I want you to do it
in Spanish and I want you to do it in
English in a few seconds encouraging
people not to procrastinate maybe some
Muslims got some non-muslims brothers in
him our brothers in humanity is like man
this makes sense man the guy was there
and he went from a way of life that
didn't make sense then he went to party
agnostic and through all of that
confusion he prayed directly to God
Allah facilitated away and now he's got
peace he knows his purpose but some
people they procrastinate and you know
what they get nowhere so what what for
the let's say Floyd money Mayweather he
gets these letters and he's like man you
know what they're right and he's not
distracted by all the money but now for
him not to procrastinate what he got to
say to Floyd
Allah says in the Quran that that this
life is just a mere enjoyment a
temporary enjoyment but the life in the
hereafter is much better and this is
something that I tell a lot of people
that this is temporary this is not gonna
last the money is not gonna last when
you pass away that money is gonna be
spread to somewhere else you're gonna be
there
alone and you don't want to be that
person who's wretched you want to be
that one who is given who was shown
mercy and eventually enter paradise
where all those riches that you had in
this world are gonna be multiplied by
billions gazillions whatever it is so
don't waste time don't waste time being
caught up in this mere enjoyment and
focus on what your purpose in life is
focus on what your God intended for you
to do in this life and to be successful
but in a way of by pleasing him and
worshiping him alone Allah the creator
of the heavens in the earth the one who
created this whole universe and
everything the one who Jesus prayed to
may he reward you thank you very much
for being with us thank you we've come
to the end of another exciting show here
in Aditya we're here
week you know catch us internationally
we're viewed all over the globe on many
satellite channels and if you're
catching us on the TV continued tune in
same time same channel or you can visit
us at the Dean show com to catch many of
our programs and procrastination is
something that is a tool that Shaitaan
the devil uses don't procrastinate know
that you've got one shot to get it right
one life to live and get it right now
because at the end you'll be in the
grave the dirt will be in your mouth and
it's over it's finished and all the
wealth that you have compiled will not
save you at all from what comes next
it's your actions developing yourself to
live a righteous life a pious life a
life that brings peace and happiness and
it's according to God's game plan not
your desires and Floyd money Mayweather
the invitation is to him and 250 and to
all the celebrities out there and the
laymen and the white collar black collar
work or yellow Chinese everyone has the
potential to submit alone to the Creator
that happens in earth and not his
creation and to live a good wholesome
organic righteous life right - Floyd we
have the opportunity he's in jail right
now send him a letter on why he should
accept Islam the benefits of it and why
he should be a Muslim one who submitted
himself to the one God all the beautiful
rewards that come with that write him a
letter and don't forget every week we're
here pick up the new dunya - dino so
share it with your friends and your
family and if you want operators are
standing by right now if you want to
accept your life how can I do it 1 800
662 m we don't need your money don't
worry we're not trying to sell you some
fairy dust or any other another hocus
pocus mumbo jumbo call us right now if
you want to accept the way of life from
the creator of the heavens and earth is
simple it is only one God worship Him
not his creation and Muhammad is the
last and final messenger and then you
accept Jesus Moses Abraham they were all
messages of God none of them call people
to submit to themselves or to saints or
to idols or icons only to God call us